good morning in the gym right now and
guess what I'm going to be sharing with
you my app routine together with my
upper body routine as well
[Music]
look at how compact this whole setup is
I've got my camera right here my light
just in case it gets too dark when I
want to film to brighten up the whole
image and I've got my crib
let's start our workouts when I workout
in the morning I prefer the Train faster
so there will be three super sets and
for higher reps with shorter rest time
let's start with a quick 5 to 10 minutes
warm
I've done my mama and we're going to
start with our first super set which
will be working on our back muscles it's
going to be a cable roll as well as a
plank
roller which will also really target
your core let's go when you pull the
cable squeeze your back muscles and hold
it for two counts keep your elbows
pointed back and close to your body and
when you're holding the squat keep your
back straight chest up and engage your
core throughout
[Music]
so I like to work on one machine and one
free wait again with plan bro you will
not only be working back in your upper
body but really on your core as well so
today's workout is all about engaging
your core muscles to keep your balance
spread your feet wider than shoulder
width apart point your elbows back and
bring the dumbbell close to your hips
brace your core keep your back flat and
avoid movement from your hips
once I've completed three rounds of the
first superset I'll get back onto the
treadmill and do three minutes of
sprinting
[Music]
this is going to be chess and hat
superset so the first workout is going
to be a bench press with leg brace lower
the bar as close to your chest and lower
legs straight down as you press the bar
up simultaneously you raise both legs
straight up and crunch your lower abs
[Music]
this is a decline fly you over with a
crunch again working on multiple muscles
your chest muscles as well as focusing
on your upper back muscles I love this
workout so what you'll need is a pair of
my quick dumbbells and let's get started
start by performing a dumbbell fly then
transition to a pull over by bringing
both dumbbells over your head as you
pull the dumbbells up engage your upper
abs and crunch your body all the way up
[Music]
once you've completed your chest and abs
a superset get back onto the treadmill
and sprint for another three minutes all
right final superset is going to be just
solely working on your core muscles okay
so it's gonna be on your upper your
lower as well as your obliques so let's
complete today's workout keeping both
legs straight brace your core and lift
them straight up control and slowly
lower them down
avoid using momentum to swing your legs
up
[Music]
final killer at work after today this
torture piece of equipment and will out
only roll the will forward as far as you
can without arching your lower back or
tipping your hips then brace a core and
roll the wheel back in one motion
keep it on straight throughout
[Music]
and that was my final three minutes of
sprint so this is my ad routine in the
gym not just working on my core but also
working on my upper body my chest and my
back muscles as well remember short rest
time
aim for higher reps and complete at
least three sets okay if you do this
routine trust me you will start to have
a rock-solid ad and you will be burning
fat more efficiently so try this out
I don't usually vlog my gym routine but
if you do enjoy this video do give me a
thumbs up let me know in the comments
below if you do want to watch it more of
my gym routine what do I do in the gym
and maybe more vlogs as well let me know
in the comments below don't forget also
subscribe to my youtube channel and
check out my other videos on my channel
as well